the DNA testing company 23andme says it
can now tell customers if they are at a
higher risk for developing type 2
diabetes health information is a major
reason for the rapid growth in gene
testing 23andme and ancestry DNA now
have roughly more than 28 million
customers combined now the tests can
also expose surprising family secrets
including unknown relatives and
biological parents Tony to cope will
brave the tests himself Tony would you
find out good morning I had a reason to
be concerned but in fact we all have
reason to be concerned when we take
these tests you spit into a little tube
you mail it in and then you wait for the
results and at that point watch out
because when that DNA report comes back
everything you think you know about
yourself and your family can change in
an instant
Katy canning never exactly looked like
her parents my mom would tell me when I
was growing up
oh you're part Native American you're
Native American but when she finally
took a home DNA test about five years
ago she got a lot more truth than she
expected she's part Jamaican for
starters and her biological father is
not the man who raised her but a
traveling guitarist named Baron Duncan a
Jamaican touring guitarist caning also
learned that Baron Duncan had at least
four other children her half siblings so
you grew up thinking you were the oldest
of two and in fact you're the oldest of
five exactly did it look like you so
much really meeting my brother Stephen
for the first time it was like looking
at my twin
I could really started crying as soon as
I saw him I found my birth mom is with
23andme just to get to hold her again
canning is one of millions who have
turned to home DNA tests and one of many
who have had their sense of identity
shaken by the results 23andme and
ancestry DNA both warn customers that
they could receive shocking information
but neither company offers genetic
counseling as part of their standard
package people are smart and capable
they can make sense of it
Emily Germont Conley is vice president
of business development at
three and me she believes customers can
handle genetic information just as they
do the results of other home exams
people take a pregnancy test at home and
if it's positive which is significant
information they then take the next step
of talking to a doctor and we think that
DNA tests are very much in the same vein
ancestry DNA says it takes the potential
impact of complex discoveries very
seriously and as a team available for
people with more sensitive queries but
DNA tests also raise questions about
privacy 23andme says it won't share
customer medical data with third parties
unless given explicit consent and the
company says it uses two-factor
authentication and encryption to protect
genetic results and has never been
hacked
but privacy expert Peter Swire says just
one breach would be hard to fix if you
have a credit card stolen you cancel it
and you get a new credit card in two
days if your DNA gets revealed to the
world or to the hacker it's really hard
to get new DNA just doesn't happen
cap on still we took a test ourselves
and I braced for a surprise I am an only
child of unmarried parents who lived a
wild and crazy hippie existence that
never came
26.6% Italian as expected with the first
name like Tony caning though is still
working through the meaning of her own
results so you're now Jamaican American
I guess okay that's a weird thing like
can I say am I allowed to say that I
don't know like can a DNA test tell me
what I am and like what my identity is I
don't know but she is sure of one thing
he doesn't care like what did you know
DNA test says like he I've been his
since the moment I was born family isn't
just blood you know family is like what
you make it and family is your heart and
you know like my dad's my dad you know
he'll walk me down the aisle one day
it's Katie there Katie told us her
biological dad died before she could
meet him but her mother did come clean
about him in the end saying and I think
this is an exact quote it was the 80s
when my mom said as well
23andme says by the way it loves stories
like these because it underscores that
we all have DNA from all over the world
and we are all immigrants from somewhere
so you are still an only child I'm still
an only child as of now katie has a
great attitude about the additions to
her family doesn't feel like it was a
loss in not getting to meet her
biological father but the shocks can
keep coming in cases like this because
as more people take the DNA test more of
these connections come up so I may not
be out of I like how she said family
isn't just blood but I'm fascinated by
your family to see the couple yeah well
my said you were concerned was dad a
rolling stone dad was not exactly
careful with his DNA in Miami in the
1980s
you know occupationally he was in the
drug business and there was a lot of fun
to be had yeah you don't mean
pharmaceuticals yeah well that's you
yeah well be on the lookout for any I'm
showing up at the studio asking for Tony
to go you know what we stay well you
always learned something new on this
show thank you Tony that was really
interesting
oh and risky for 23andme yeah really
good company